one of the ways you can tell that a
movement is complete BS
or that a narrative
its main purpose is to usert power and
control
is if the movement really has no
definitive conclusion
so we think about the War on Drugs
okay the war on terrorism
how would you determine when we're
finished
are we ever going to eradicate terrorism
are we going to eradicate drugs the
answer is no right so what this tells
you is that the people that are pushing
this narrative really don't want it to
end because the narrative itself
allows them to use serp power control
and wealth right it's like the the green
movement you know the and I'm not here
to debate climate change or anything
like that but what I can tell you is
that the let's go say the global Elite
they don't care about the climate they
don't care about the temperature in the
ocean they're just using this as a
trojan horse that has no end therefore
you know if it's 20 50 if it's 2100 well
that's fantastic because it's so far in
the future it's so ambiguous it's so
difficult to pin down that you just need
to trust me and we just need to do
whatever I say and you just need to hand
over your personal freedom and liberty
because this Boogeyman out there that
you really can't quantify so again
whether it's the war on terrorism the
War on Drugs whether it's uh you know
this woke movement you know how would
you define if or how would you determine
if we've done enough
yep the the you know the the gay folks
they're they're good to go we can move
on to the next uh topic of discussion or
we can move on to the next Battle Cry
you we'll never ever ever get there and
that's the intention and I think that's
kind of if you're trying to go through
all these Global movements that we have
in the world today that's the ultimate
sniff test
is can you define a logical conclusion
if the answer is no then you know the
people pushing it don't care about the
narrative they simply care about power
and control and a lot of times the
people who support that who are who
identify with like say the woke side of
things or the even the conservative side
of things their personality who they are
as a person is invested in that constant
churn of keeping that that uh their
momentum their own activism they're the
useful idiots as Stalin would say or uh
Lenin are they as Milton Friedman called
them the do-gooders and they just get
caught up they're just kind of the
people that are pulling the strings they
understand that they can take advantage
of those people and get them to do their
their bidding and that they have good
intentions you know the do-gooders and
the useful idiots they have good
intentions they want the world to be a
better place but unfortunately they're
just they've drank the Kool-Aid of the
puppet tier we've become very good at
and I put this in this in my fifth book
in the I think it's in uh the first
chapter it's called brand management I
talk about churn marketing I don't know
if you're familiar with the turn of the
term of churn marketing and what it is
is for instance Tinder doesn't want you
to have a good relationship they don't
want you to get married they don't want
you to find the love your soulmate and
the love of your life because the moment
they do they lose a customer right they
delete them so as long as you have a
shitty relationship and you come back to
the to the app that's what they want
they get you back into the churn it's
just like the politicians don't want
your life to improve right they want
because if your life improves then you
don't need them right but if your life
stays the same if it gets worse then you
need them even more they stay in power
they keep the control they keep the
wealth so they want to keep you down I
mean it's it's it's it's to their it's
in their best interests and we do this
on so many different levels like of
course my wheelhouse is red pill and
intersection Dynamics which I just said
you know Tinder but we can't watch a
movie anymore we have to watch a series
we have to watch a Netflix series you
know if you I just finished Ozark and
I'm like no the series is over it was so
good right when we were just like
agonizing over this but it's because we
watch from from the beginning all the
way to the end of what season four
whatever it was uh was it stranger
things is coming out you know the last
the final chapters of of stranger things
which is not a bad thing but the thing
is if you think about it if you watch
stranger things from season one all the
way up to where they're at right now how
many hours have you spent watching
stranger things how many hours did you
did I watch you know Ozark what a good
series right but what it does is we
don't know how to tell a story anymore
it used to be that we could watch a
movie in two hours it was like beginning
development character development uh you
know setbacks climax aftermath and then
hopefully maybe there's a sequel or
something within two hours we used to be
able to to do that we enjoyed that now
we hate that we hate the two-hour format
because we're like well where's the next
one where's the next thing and I'll just
joke I'm gonna I'm gonna sell my wife
out here in just a second if I want to
go and watch like Lord of the Rings
right if I want to watch The Fellowship
of the Ring or two towers or something
like that that's a three-hour investment
because it's a three hour long movie
right but we'll sit there and we'll
watch like four or five hours of of
whatever series is going on because it's
just one after the next after the next
and that brings you back into the churn
now that's just the way that we consume
our our entertainment right now we're
not looking for writers who can ride a
stand-alone a story we're looking for
somebody who can have staying power in a
series we watch series now we don't
watch movies anymore now try the thing
and I'll just for you playing the home
game out there try to think of other
churns that you get locked into that
just keeps going but it could be
politics it could be religion it could
be your ideology it could be what it
could be your family for that matter but
we're we're so we think in term terms of
churn right now and we don't even
realize it so if you like that clip
click right here to watch another or if
you want to watch the entire saucecast
click right here
[Music]